sometimes they don't laugh and what is
what is your like I always ask comics
like a story of getting booed on stage
or just like the most epic bomb they've
had in their career which what stands
out to you now you know usually it's
funny usually people who boo now usually
one boo and it's usually you said
something they didn't like it's a go
[ __ ] yourself [ __ ] child oh you
didn't hear you got offended I think you
just laughed at five minutes of [ __ ]
let me making fun of this guy's face you
fine with that
mmm sure he wasn't I'm sure deep down
somewhere he was like this hurts but he
was laughing at it but you don't really
get booed anymore there's gotta be some
bombs you've had I've had bombs but I
mean I deserve them you know shouldn't
have been there you know outdoor [ __ ]
yeah I don't really bomb anymore I do
good oh yeah this is like in the early
days when you're like still trying to
figure it out you know I've bombed the
wood I mean the worst most I mean I
don't mind I've had big bombs but the
most terrifying bomb I had was in
Buffalo outside of Buffalo I did it all
black underground nightclub yes and I
was you know I did I did black rooms all
the time in New York and I loved just
all black crowd yeah I did yeah I do I'm
in Atlanta all the time yeah you're
funny you're funny exactly they do not
not want to laugh they want to laugh but
I do stink you'll know about it
yep but if you're funny there's no
better and it doesn't matter what you
say if it's funny the left mm-hmm and I
remember I just was so cocky I I took
the train up there and I'm oh the guy
that picked me up was a legitimate pimp
like he was a pimp
he had a big medallion and he gave me a
big bucket of chicken wings and I was
like I was just sitting in the car like
thirty wings in a bucket and this big
SUV and
he said yeah most comics we get they
love those I was like okay I really want
wings right now you know and he dropped
me off for the hotel and this other guy
knocked on the door big [ __ ] he
came in
I'm here to pay you and he counted out
the cash 2500 bucks cash on the bed was
counted I go I trust you goes count it I
was like okay okay and one two and I
remember I did this gig and the kid that
went up before me was a local emcee he
hated it that I was there he was a kill
using this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and
you're not headlining me and I he was
mad he would not buried me I went up and
bombed I mean and this guy from the back
said something and I started thrashing
him and I was getting laughs my God look
at you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
toothpick [ __ ] or the [ __ ] wife
beater on go [ __ ] is and he charged the
stage they had to grab him he was
literally a murderer he was like a
killer in a gang and I just was [ __ ]
him so then I just walked off then they
had the kid went back up he goes I told
you this [ __ ] they bring these
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that and he start
trashing me they were dying laughing and
this big guy walked up and he goes yo
you got to go up and defend yourself you
go to battle like I would like it was
like mm all right you know like I
grabbed it
no I'm good he goes no you have no
choice you've got to go defend use and
he handed me a mic and as I'm walking up
this kid was thrashing me is ignite man
you do this to me Mom it was a nightmare
she said it all stopped i sat over in
this room and the guy walked up because
y'all be with you in a minute he was mad
he was mad that he had paint paid me all
this money and I'm sitting there for two
and a half hours I turned into a
nightclub so two and a half hours I'm
just sitting in this little corner
finally I just went to this woman who
was dating this guy or whatever and I
said can I go please a shooting song
baby alright and this guy walked over
and he goes yo through this key to it
like a 14 year old kid he's a little
cousin it was drive this [ __ ]
home so this little kid drove me home in
this big I don't care we get pulled over
I know you don't have a life
he got me back to the hotel I got my
money I went to the train station
I hid between a soda machine and a
vending machine until the train came and
like 6:30 in the morning oh and I just
find I got by out of there she [ __ ]
terrifying twenty five hundred cash 25
minute cash in my sock
oh my waiting for somebody to just I was
just waiting for a couple cars to pull
up yo I'm gonna need that money back I
was like yeah see Elena I spent 20 on a
Coke and a bag of nachos yeah how long
into your career was that
[Music]